oh we get to see Correll I don't like
this happy holidays everybody check
Decker how you doing I'm excited I'm
excited I love this game very much but
man I'm excited about what we're going
to do do it baby yeah rhymes against
humanity we're about to commit right
here we are back with another episode of
potato mode the show where we take your
favorite games and turn them into
absolute mud and we're taking GameSpot's
favorite game of 2019 SEC Euro shadows
that's why so it was our game of the
year and now we're gonna ruin it I'm
just gonna kind of wander around for a
hot minute give Jake a chance to get his
bearings in order because it's that
girl's a tough game and we're about to
make it a lot tougher on you or maybe
it'll make it easier I'm actually
curious maybe you know if you have less
things to focus actly you remove
barriers
[Music]
all right oh nice
wasn't wasn't clean but got the job done
I'm here on potato mode we start by just
seeing what we can do naturally with the
game oh yeah yeah get up there there's a
really nice view all right okay let's
hop into them settings this game is
currently set to max settings you can
set it to low but then let's go into the
advanced and see exactly what we're what
we're turning off here texture okay
that's pretty much off not really that
much in the way in graphic settings yeah
I feel like they're games typically
don't have options now it's okay and
still looks pretty dang good gotta be
honest that doesn't look it really made
really too much of a difference like the
shadows don't look as sharp and yeah I
mean I it still looks pretty good though
it still looks pretty darn good to me
here we are with the Nvidia profile
inspector trying true we're gonna stick
with our usual formula which for those
of you new is we're gonna go down here
and we're gonna mess with a couple of
settings so many numbers I don't know
how you're doing I have faith though I
don't know I'm doing either I'm just
copying what Joey did Joey had gotten to
a point when he used to do this where he
just knew like he had it memorized and I
was always like dude okay what we're
gonna turn that off we're gonna get that
quality to high performance okay we're
gonna apply changes and let's boot it on
up and see man all right I'm excited to
see what Wow all right okay we go back
to that uh that Vista we had earlier
yeah let's do that
well the blood oh I missed it I was so
focused on it's just like a flat you
know it's it's not that bad like I looks
like video game backgrounds if you look
closely yeah it's just everything else
in the foreground that I'm like
yikes that's the thing with the wood
when you mess with the game this way and
you just got these it almost becomes a
its own art style yeah like coming off
there like all the leaves are gone
I almost look naked yeah if anything
it's kind of like we're saying before
you we've removed barriers you also have
an advantage now yeah this is this is
how you really speedrun set your oh yeah
oh look at the it's just a square like
the symbol the kanji that appears
okay you should I want to see yo God
dang it
let me out of here
oh my god
dang it
oh my god please over again I hope so
okay we did it took longer than expected
oh I forgot he is poisonous look at the
poison on you look at this little hair
tie it's just floating you can see like
a faint outline of her hair oh you can
see here like a little hair ties yeah
all right all right man this is maybe my
favorite track in the whole game yeah
it's so good I used it in our game of
the Year mamta I made for a secular oh I
hope you can be here because if we get
to the the second the second fight
there's fire everywhere oh I can beat
her you can't be here
oh yeah it's pretty brutal I know your
thumbnail right there oh yeah you know
you've made the wrong decision well you
should know right when you have to fight
her but with all the fire everywhere oh
I can't see the fire oh wait maybe he's
just not out yet no no no there's fire
the ground is red you had a good idea
why don't we we could maybe go check out
the beginning of the game yeah it's cool
seeing all like the individual pieces
and how they fit together and stuff like
that yeah you how you get weird
breakdown like seeing stuff like how
Sakura's hair is completely gone but the
only Emma's hair o is invisible but then
owls hair was like part of his model
more you're like oh that's like a each
character's hair was done differently
yeah neat like that's really interesting
oh we get to see core oh why does he
have a weird lump on his head
no that's so weird I don't like this
sure make this as quick as possible
there's something on the flat square
blood
hello come on dude Hey Dude what's up
what is he doing all right you guys
we'll attack right no this is the glitch
that I ran into before oh really
where I like no one would fight back
wait maybe that guy will nope
hello potato mode just got more
interesting I've never had this glitch
before I had it on Xbox recently but I
never had it before
now I've uh I don't think I had any
glitches with this game remember this
game being a pretty smooth experience I
like this guy just hanging out up here
oh wow oh but look Oh none of the grass
is there this is like one of my favorite
shots in the whole game yeah I know it
when you tell you that that one is
completely so look how he's floating too
a little bit
oh yeah oh he looks pretty cool kinda
yeah yeah I don't know what that's from
some one thing it's like the shadows not
yeah okay I can't get to deal with that
without McKee recounting right
well like the Terran escape I like the
trees in the background these little
sticks Oh
oh yeah he's like and the hair on the
mask is gone
whoa what's with this uh I don't know I
wonder if it's just because oh they
normally wear this giant yeah he is just
like any other sorry gone hello
oh it's the cattle
[Laughter]
I love fighting these guys
nice the destruction mixed with the
heavy shoes really good nice hey dude I
don't know you're gonna do this part you
can't the grass
where is he where is he oh now excuse
there's no tear normally there supposed
to be a tear in it but there's not one
oh it's like I think the texture is
supposed to be like a cloth you got you
got a go man I know I'm just watching
them go you can't wait too long dude I I
definitely prefer the Japanese overall
but uh this man makes you regret they
the English vo for gyobu really puts us
all into the performance he's really
shiny
there he is Horace like gold Oh Wyatt
everybody that was a pretty good look at
Sakura all potato five thanks for
watching if you like this show we aren't
doing it regularly the way we use to you
but we try and bring it back on special
occasions when it makes sense so feel
free in the comments to let us know what
games do you think would be good for if
there's any any fun ones there's a lot
of games coming out in 2020 yeah I think
will be fun I'm looking at you cyberpunk
so until then thanks for watching guys
you
[Music]